we opened the boxes look it's very cool
and you know i keep these on because
there's nothing in this one because it's
on my finger already these are very cool
original grain
uh we sold out of the sunglasses last ad
obviously because look how fashionable
they are uh if you want something go get
it now
uh original grain
look this company rocks father's day is
coming up and we have the perfect gift
for every dad um
and uh they're gonna sell out of the
inventory and we're gonna sell out of
our inventory before father's day so
make sure you get them early at
originalgreen.com
lifeline for 30 off the stuff they have
is cool check out this watch if you want
to boss it up the way i move it around
like this it looks extra sexy the way
i'm doing it like that doesn't it yeah
it looks good with the tattoo yeah uh
look original green is this really great
company uh
been making watches from unique
materials and that's why it's very cool
and unique for almost a decade every
watch we sell we plant a tree so if you
want to be responsible and fashion and a
fashionista hop on over to original
grain uh they've planted over half a
million trees
we offer a buy back guarantee so if you
don't love the watch we'll buy it back
over 20 000 five-star reviews are you
one of them get on board so many so many
use code lifeline at originalgrain.com
lifeline go to
originalgrain.com
lifeline and use the code lifeline to
get 30 off site wide all right
everything they make watches from other
sustainable materials like 100 recycled
ocean plastic reclaimed military ammo
wood crates it's very nice it's very
good for the environment it's like you
could wear this and you could be on par
with pharrell because that's what he
does too and are you cool like him well
maybe if you go to
originalgrain.com
lifeline and use the code lifeline to
get 30 off site wide
get your father's day gift taken care of
today today
lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or a licensed professional
[Music]
did you see the christian bale playing
the thor guy
and he looks like he shouldn't i i did
see that and dude they'd show a
christian bail we'll put it on the video
but we showed christian bale playing i
guess his name is gore the god butcher
sadarke on the new thor movie but he the
picture that they showed him he's like
this
he's got diarrhea he's constantly looks
like he's [ __ ]
and it's it's crazy to be a god butcher
and still be
and look like you're [ __ ] i think
all that god butching makes you
constipated yeah so he's like
yeah killing too many gods lately
yeah
dude why do the most like acclaimed
actors
do
marvel [ __ ] well i i don't know small
roles in marvel shows yeah i know you
know he should they shot him out in like
four days i think that probably well
money right it's money but it's like
dude you ha your christian bail you have
enough money i guess so but wouldn't
i think people just are like no i don't
want to do it until then it's like well
we'll give you 20 million and he's like
all right [ __ ] it it's a week like why
wouldn't you do it like why wouldn't you
do it
i don't know
you'd think some people would care more
about legacy than than just people yeah
but nobody's gonna remember him as that
guy they're going to remember christian
bell the great [ __ ] actor they're not
going to think they're not going to be
like
and let's not forget he played gore the
butcher dude i would go the way things
are going i wouldn't be surprised and
then even still then he wants to [ __ ]
solidify his legacy that way too
right okay so now i'm pissed though
i mean i'm on your side dude are you
okay well i mean
what's your argument you don't like
marvel movies you think that they're bad
and then so you think that when a like a
good actor does it my arnold
my argument is when
a really like jessica chastain did it
too in one of the x-men movies she's
like
tiny role yeah in like a spin-off of an
x-men movie yeah and it's like what are
you doing
why are you doing that and i guess in
her case she probably doesn't make as
much money as a guy who was batman in
four movies right movies whatever oh
you're saying he was batman yeah he was
already [ __ ] batman three times but
he thought but you have to understand
christian bale is probably like this guy
that thinks that oh i'm gonna do batman
i'm gonna be batman but it's gonna be an
artistic version christopher nolan has
[ __ ] convinced me and then he's doing
it you know and he thinks it's good and
a lot of people think it's good and
whether or not you and i think it's good
then it you know it's all subjective
anyway so
they're rationalizing
also it's [ __ ] actors are ego driven
he also loves the franchise [ __ ] he was
doing terminator that's when he when he
made that tape yeah yeah good for you
that one yeah oh good for you
and how was it
busting and so mad that a guy
[ __ ]
had an orgasm first
and no you're not gonna get to have it i
was it
dude yeah that's that was that's given
me more joy than almost that thing was
really funny good for you
yeah that's not what's the thing where
he's like
no but when he says he did something
like ah that's not all right that's not
how it is right or something what's the
[ __ ] thing it's not nobody does
something like
very like
casual in it that's not what it is
yeah i forgot yeah yeah but the elephant
in the other in the room is yeah i got
this new [ __ ] hoodie on oh see i
wasn't even noticing it but
because
it's such a big elephant in the room
that's almost taking over the whole room
that you're like it's like right here i
can't even notice it's enough yeah so
yeah it's the new life rips hoodie and
it's out there crystalia.com and it's
[ __ ] ugh the [ __ ] puff is just
wonderful i mean dude it's you know what
we're done with we see
you know we're done with hoodies that
just stay level right you want you want
the [ __ ] levels you want a hoodie
with levels you want a hoodie that's
just kind of the fabric and then also
whoopsie daisy you're walking down the
hoodie and oh [ __ ] and you got to jump
up on the [ __ ] extra level so it's
puffed out and it's the new hoodie
and i can already tell you they're
flying off the shelves but whatever
chrisleya.com for the new life rip city
and guess what dude what we are in talks
of making the first lifeline merch yeah
we're making the first lifeline marches
and so uh so that's what [ __ ] how you
did wu but um
try to sound like it was far away oh
well they can see you're not far away
well some people are just listening so
anyway um
that's what's up
so we're getting our first lifeline
merch is coming up soon so guys just
[ __ ] wait with baited breath and then
let's get a little business out of the
way too right oh boy i know because
guess what
i'm a traveling man you are right i
don't just sit in the la i mean a lot of
people come to l.a they say lla right
they wait for auditions they do their
thing
i'm a traveling man yeah okay so i'm
going to be in atlanta yes
september 9. so yes i'm going to be in
washington dc yes okay september 10th so
yes i'm going to be in stockton and
oakland september 23rd and 24th yes and
peoria illinois and rockford illinois
october 7th and october 8th yes
and i'm going to be in raleigh october
21st yes
and savannah georgia they're like are
you coming here and the answer is yes
i'm going to be in there october 22nd
okay denver colorado i'm going to play
the bellcore theodore theater theodore
the bellco theater of roosevelt no
november 6 and i'm going to be a boston
massachusetts and jacksonville florida
in november december so guys go to
chrisley.com get your tickets
and uh and that's what's up and guess
what it's too hot so i'm gonna take this
hoodie off
but that's what's up but you got the ace
ventura drip on and that's really great
i like that even too hot in this yeah
yeah i mean i love this shirt i was
wondering if i should unbutton one more
or keep it this amount of unboxing one
more or let's see
let's see no it's good like that
so you don't want to see no i mean like
you look like you're a cool guy that you
could maybe trust in miami but like if
you unbutton it you're a guy you can't
trust okay well
lifeline if you have a question send in
a video
watchlifeline.com and uh and this is our
show lifeline and uh
you know
that's what's up that's that's
absolutely have you been having fun
doing this show
i've been having a lot of fun i've been
looking a lot forward to it and i'll
tell you what i've been looking did you
want my answer did you just want to talk
well you breathed and you took too long
right the breathing doesn't is not
taking too long it's just breathing okay
but the answer is yes i've been having
fun after
after every episode i always think wow
that was so fun
that what i just said sounded like i was
lying worse playback i absolutely was
not lying
um
i do too and i guess what and this is
how you really know the test of how fun
this podcast is okay okay and by the way
share the podcast if you like the
podcast leave a comment oh and give
advice to the people that we give advice
to in the comments because they're
checking they're checking they are
actually yeah and they respond to you
guys i've seen it but um what what i was
gonna say is i like to drive i even get
excited there's sometimes there's so
much traffic in l.a oh yeah yeah and i
still you know i drive and i hate the
traffic but i'm excited to get here and
what does he do he stops at the coffee
bean and tea leaf and today you weren't
even late i wasn't late i thought i gave
myself time i gave myself a lot of time
to make it and there was zero traffic
that's the thing about la you never know
if there's gonna be traffic or not but
giving yourself a lot of time is exactly
how
one remains
on time see what i'm saying you don't
get extra credit for giving yourself a
lot of time that's what you're supposed
to do when traffic is inevitable and in
la it is inevitable right but we work
with our circumstances and we grow with
them right so when i leave and then i'm
late because the traffic is too bad and
then i leave and then i'm late because
the traffic is too bad then i give
myself extra time and then i'm 40
minutes early now that's too much so the
next time i might be like well maybe i
don't need to leave so early
but you do but then i'm 40 minutes early
again maybe
maybe but that's better than being 40
minutes late 40 minutes early is better
than being 40 minutes late yes yes
only pretty much for the people that
aren't you
yeah which is ideal we're more important
yeah we get it but the people who aren't
you are the reason we try to be on time
yeah otherwise you get if it's just you
going somewhere you get there whenever
the [ __ ] you want true get there
whenever the [ __ ] you get there i got
coffee being a tea leaf on the guy and
then this guy goes like this hey man
dude
can i get a picture with you and i say
sure and he said i was gonna yell out
from across the room but this isn't the
hood oh and i said oh yeah and he said
yeah so i had to keep it really nice and
then he takes out his phone and it was
one of those phones that you fold out
like a laser disk
dude and he's going like this and it's
so big right that it's almost like
dipping and he has to use his other kind
of phone bro i don't know these guys
from the future the hood in the future
and he goes like this and he and he just
and and he couldn't even like the button
was so far over that he could barely and
he hit it and he was like shaking and
he's like bro that's so [ __ ] awesome
man thank you for what you do and i was
like all right cool and then i left
with the iced americano and i got in the
car and then
somebody was walking by i didn't know if
it was a man or a woman oh okay but
that's fine right that is fine but also
such a bad ending in that event
absolutely nothing to do with what
preceded it you know oh [ __ ]
nothing to do with it it's all good uh
do you want to go do you want to start
yeah okay cool let's do it
hey guys this is kirsten from jersey um
hell yeah new jersey
we're from jersey we like anyway so i
have a hard hitting question for you
guys we
how do you feel
about phone calls just literally picking
up the phone hey what's up
i personally love it i think it's a
great way to communicate with your
friends chat say what's up well
literally none of my friends answer my
phone calls like and then in the next
breath they'll text me like oh hey
what's up mm-hmm yeah like [ __ ] i would
have told you if you would've
yeah
yeah so yeah i'm just like i'm wondering
if is it just like an invasion of
privacy like should i text you first
like why does everyone feel like it's so
invasive to call someone or pick up the
phone yeah just asking you know
for me really
anyway
yeah it's so sometimes personal like
dude
text everyone text you know like even
mom is like yeah what's up yeah yeah
right uh but it's so and like you have
you been texting with someone and then
they call and you're like oh [ __ ] they
know i'm looking that's the only unfair
move it's unfair dude it's unfair the
thing the thing that she's talking about
though is i actually agree with her i
wonder why everyone is so afraid oops
i'm talking because i don't want to and
you only do it while i'm talking i know
but i will be ready to do what i'm
talking
for me all right okay so
but when you call it out no one's
hearing this when you call it i'm
hearing it
okay
so i'm hearing it all right and
she is right in that it's annoying that
people are like this now people do
basically whatever they can to not have
to get on the phone right that is
annoying and and also i do that
yes
so i'm of both minds i do that too i
wait it's annoying no it's i think i
don't call me never call me see i don't
like that rule but i feel that way but i
don't like that i'm like that
i have honestly
uh
cancelled a call and texted the person
no what's up yeah that's unbelievable
i'm real it's unbelievably rude it's not
though if you have the dynamic of that
sure if you have a certain friend that
would find that funny yeah
because i could find it it's funny or
you're not in my camp
okay do you understand
so militant about no funny camp what's
up
what do you want to know nothing is
worth a phone call
i don't know i i don't like picking up
either and i'll often let it ring but
i find that me being like that and other
people being like that i find that
[ __ ] frustrating i do times are
changing though and you know and pretty
soon it's going to be like don't text me
dude just think it and send it over
through the thought link i'll get it
right but until that is the case right
texting is the thing we got to figure
out a way to co-exist you think that
back in like the [ __ ] 1200s people
were like another [ __ ] pigeon with a
note on it it's so personal
maybe letters they were like that with
um let's talk about how jersey that girl
was though
but then after she said it and and then
she started talking more i thought that
is such a jersey yeah yeah uh-huh it's
so jersey to be subtly jersey yeah
that's you know what i'm talking about
like the people who are like listen i
talk to them all day you know that's
that's like the 80s 90s type jerseys
exist yeah sure this
this woman is like the new age subtly
jersey most jersed out [ __ ] i've
ever seen i mean
yeah she's jersed out so um you know
i think that honestly maybe they're just
like not picking up the phone call
because they're like i'm not this jersey
like she's probably calling other people
from jersey and just text she probably
texts people with the fingernail emojis
you know super jersed out but she's uh
yeah she's you know i have friends that
like to talk like who i have a buddy who
[ __ ] calls me all the time and it's
just dude there's one possibility that
we haven't considered which is that
she's basically saying
why does nobody pick up my phone calls
mm-hmm
and you're saying it's maybe on her
maybe yeah but i don't i don't think so
but maybe yeah i don't know she seems
like nice and [ __ ] and like but but like
and also like i i really like a lot of
people i like when they come over i like
when they're in my lives and like when
they're talking but when when they call
me i'm like come on man
i don't like being called what's worse
face time's worse right because you
gotta people are like i like to facetime
why don't we facetime and it's like dude
i don't how about this it's worse than
phone call because not only do you have
to
um
not text and be c conscious of only the
phone call you also got to hold your
[ __ ] arm up yeah yeah and it's like
i'm strong obviously my [ __ ]
you know it goes dummy right like a lot
of people if they see me from the back
there's no way they can tell who it is
because it looks like i'm wearing a
shield oh okay like just
at cat at bay right in case [ __ ] goes
down yeah because of my back's lumped up
but like when i [ __ ] i'm holding it
like this i still get tired i'm a human
right okay but i also think there's more
cars more frustrating than an
unsolicited facetime if we're supposed
to facetime at a certain time or if you
text me hey let's facetime and i say
okay
great but if you just [ __ ] facetime
me
wow so [ __ ] gotta empty it out i'll
tell you what got to get this down
dousia okay i tell you what the number
one people who face time in public
[Music]
oh i and i will say this here we go and
i'm going to say it i'm going to say
this first so it doesn't sound racist
white
chicks
do you understand so far so far not
racist because i'm white okay also tied
with black dudes oh really
dudes it's like they want you to hear
that they have friends and see they have
friends
sup
and for some reason that [ __ ] loom is
louder on a black dude's phone it's just
like what's up yo what are you doing
chilling bee
chilling i don't see it yeah
that's the other guy i don't see it a
lot just like what's going on here in a
diner facetiming in public is just a
no-no i think yeah general [ __ ] dude
that's my nightmare that's my yeah yeah
it's so it's so annoying dude yeah
no good
but the phone call thing
i mean look it's like change with the
times if you can't beat them join them i
think you need to result in text i think
she needs to understand
her friends are not going to want to be
calling and you just or get a group of
friends that are like old-fashioned
she's old-fashioned she's trapped in a
young person's body she's old that's
true yeah right yeah you know so you're
saying she should get with the times and
just text get with the times and just
text or get a lot of old-fashioned
friends or just older friends maybe
there's a solution where it's like hey
can we hop on the phone you text that
first and you might get on the phone oh
oh heartbeat city dude what i mean
[ __ ] anxiety
dude hey can you talk do you want to hop
on the phone you might as well just
[ __ ] you know in the
uh you might as well just inject me with
that thing in the rock when to fight oh
the adrenaline rule the adrenaline dude
i [ __ ] i can't stand that hey can you
chat oh my god dude i want a part of you
say something different then not hey can
you chat
everything's totally fine saying like
yeah right yeah just want to [ __ ]
with you yes yeah right okay that's fine
yeah okay that's so specific but yeah
i mean it's better to be specific when
hey can you chat is like oh [ __ ] what
what did i do but i sounds like she has
a problem with that kind of person that
only wants to text but the truth is if
all your friends are like that you got
to get on board
there's no way to make them want to talk
on the phone that's only going to
alienate them if you can't beat them
join them one time i was driving uh
along the 110 freeway and i saw and
where you get onto the five freeway yeah
there's that one lane that you gotta
merge on
and everyone was
lined up so long and i went i used to go
wait to
uh
get in the back because i thought it's
respectful to wait your turn in line and
that as i was doing that i was waiting
in the back this is dude i changed this
day i changed i was waiting in the line
and i saw everybody cutting in everybody
cutting in now i don't like to do that
because i'm respectful especially when
it comes to a [ __ ] line dude i don't
cut lines yeah okay right yeah and i've
been cut before yeah but whatever dude i
keep my side of the street clean yeah
i'm waiting in line i see people cutting
in dude it takes me [ __ ] an extra 10
minutes to merge onto the five freeway
so i adopted if you can't beat em join
them and now i cut as early as i can
dude now just in general i'll crash oh
yeah oh you're gonna crash into me no
you won't so i [ __ ] get in you can't
beat them join them i cut dude i cut on
that five freeway entrance so if you
can't join what you're saying every
single time so see if we're not if we're
not all playing by the rules pandemonium
baby yeah but see you've
changed you you i've noticed that you
change your rules
based on the way other people are
behaving
and i never do that
and i'm better what it means is i'm
better because i have
hard principles i have heard you're
flimsy flappy all over the place moving
your [ __ ] around i am the way i am in
the face of whatever you agree great you
disagree great you know what it is all
the same to me i'm a chameleon and
that's what makes me such a great actor
as well
is that what which is
what you're basically that's not even at
all what i'm saying i know but you could
agree with that oh well i think you're a
great actor but that doesn't again
nothing to do with what i said thank you
just
just just in general across the board
nothing
all right we'll do another one we
definitely figured that out yeah let's
do another one we spent too much time on
that but i like what we spent too much
it right time okay go ahead let's do
another one chilling oh just wait
[ __ ] pause it absolutely passed out
was so drunk woke up
had his phone and he was like lifeline
and then [ __ ] just recorded alright
guys
a fireman christmas oh yeah love the
podcast traveling through bc doesn't
matter [ __ ] where the question is is
that
um i dated a girl in 2019 she's a cam
model
uh
she asked me in the video only one i
ever did got screen recorded
and now it's online somewhere whoa um i
don't know what to do now it's gonna be
there forever
yeah just own this grow a mustache get
in the business no no uh second thing is
i'm five eight i have along here no it's
not doesn't [ __ ] matter
yeah i know maybe he meant more of a
handlebar mustache also bro where are
you he was like on a boat it was like he
was on a boat where like they hung up
some plants yeah in this one window area
yeah and he like stuck himself in that
little wedged into that little area
i mean was he just sleeping and then
woke up and was like god or was he like
ooh that's a good [ __ ] tight spot to
do this video yeah
what i wonder also why well he takes a
lot of weird videos right
that guy yeah because he did yeah he's
not good at taking videos of himself he
said only fans or a cam model right yeah
or something so he did a video with her
yeah i guess is what he said says one
and and it's online and she put it
online it's just so [ __ ] isn't there
such thing as like uh revenge porn can't
you know like it's illegal yeah i i
think it is i don't know it's illegal
but i also think that it doesn't it's
like so hard to process you it's also um
vancouver or uh sorry canada so who
knows what the [ __ ] right the laws are
there yeah um but
definitely this isn't one of those
situations that you where you go okay
all in i'm a porn actor yeah no that's
not a good thing it's not because porn
star is one of those things that like is
thrown around like you you'll be like yo
she's a porn star and you're like really
and she did three videos and it's like
dude right
you gotta work for that star thing
people just mean act like someone who
was in porn
you know
like once even they'll say a porn star i
find that weird too
i mean i think that that guy just
basically
you know
you gotta just own it and be like yeah i
did it and she [ __ ] put it out didn't
mean for it to but how about the way i
lay it down
right how about the way i do the
horizontal mambo he doesn't have options
he doesn't have options yeah he well
what do you mean
like he's asking for advice and there's
no advice to give
all i can say is
that sucks
right i mean
yeah
you're not gonna be like well it leaked
now i'm a porn star that's not a [ __ ]
option that's just like a change in
there is this path yeah there is this
sort of thing in the world that exists
now though where it's just like lean
into whatever the [ __ ] you think people
think you are you know especially social
media wise like everyone's got a
presence digitally and trump kind of
made it so it's like all right i'm the
guy who you hate but i'm the [ __ ] i'm
gonna tell it like it is and i got my
fan base who [ __ ] believes in me ride
or die so that guy is basically
um
riding this
trump effect where it's like look she
put out a video maybe i'm just a porn
star now and [ __ ] everybody i think
that's a bad thing though i think you're
not he's not a portrait he's just in
some cam girl right video right
right
you can't just be like well i was an
extra in the latest mel gibson movie
should i just lean into this and become
a movie star yeah it's just like start
taking pictures and autographs like just
it's not like you snap your fingers and
suddenly you are the [ __ ] thing um
i saw a building i'm an architect yeah
yeah yeah so basically all this guy did
was call in to brag that he [ __ ]
somebody on camera yeah also the guy
doesn't want people to know he's [ __ ]
letting people know yeah what the [ __ ]
lifelong this is on a [ __ ] lifeline
it's got
you know millions and trillions of views
i know i don't buy this guy at all yeah
you know what dude you're a faker bro
he's a faker there might not even be a
video of you there's no video i bet oh
dude we've been had prove it send it in
to the [ __ ] show we want proof of you
and your schlong in this [ __ ] video
who [ __ ] a guy on an outside submarine
anyway she couldn't he couldn't have a
sexual partner sexual partner in that
little area anyway yeah he's never
[ __ ] on camera
and if it's not if if we're wrong
send it to us well let us
i'll get some funyuns and [ __ ] diet
coke disgusting go ahead
[ __ ] disgusting all right let's do
another one
what's up matt what's up chris elliott
west here coming from sunny los angeles
california news customer living for
about a year um pursuing my acting
career now that i've gotten a little
more comfortable in that arena and i've
found my footing in that i'd like to
branch out and do stand-up which i've
wanted to do forever but my hometown
didn't really have any open mic places
or open mic places that allowed uh
children under the age of 21. um now
that i got the fake i'm going up and i'm
doing a three minute set tonight in
about an hour um i know these questions
are going to answer late or not at all
but i'll make it quick i have a question
for chris and for matt for chris is
there anything in your career that you
realized years into it years of doing
stand up that you wish you knew just a
little bit sooner to make things easier
for you if you knew it just a couple
years prior maybe you would have been
able to find your flow better or
something maybe save me a couple years
of trial and error anyways for matt
you're hilarious i've seen your podcast
i've seen you on chris's podcast and now
i get to see you guys next to each other
weekly i couldn't be more happy that
being the case you've got to have about
15 minutes or something man i want to
see you do stand up even though it's not
your adventure you ever think about
doing it just for shits and giggles
anyways all right i'm gonna go put up my
set i'm gonna go eat [ __ ] thanks guys
i mean that guy
gives the micro machines guy a run for
his money but so fast that was i mean he
makes vince vaughn sound seem like
gandhi dude
so fast the way he was speaking and
props to you for that that was that's
gonna happen
yeah um
you started at the right time he's
starting when he wants to he's starting
when he's young enough uh
that's a what a good question that was
what a good ques i gotta say what a good
question that was for this dude to to be
so aware of his situation that that's
the question yes is is there anything
that you would have done differently
because a lot of young comedians will
come up to me and say what do i do to
make it or um do you have any advice and
you know a guy asked me the other day
and i said how long have you been doing
stand up and he said like two months and
i said there is no advice you have to
the only advice is go on stage as much
as possible but i knew that back then i
went on stage as much as possible i
would do two three fours five shows a
night in los angeles i was driving all
over creation going really you know uh
going from spot to spot i am i'm gonna
be late i'm [ __ ] this and that doing
the open mics so
you know he didn't ask for this kind of
advice but you gotta go up as much as
possible um
the he said what would i have done
differently
i don't know what i would have done
differently you know i mean i had like
my trajectory was pretty quick so i you
know i
differently would have maybe made it
take longer whatever
uh
i i
i think
just
if you just do
as many shows as possible don't ever ask
to be on shows
um which i never did anyway like people
just kind of what would i have done
differently
okay here's something i would have done
differently don't post your material
don't post your material early on it's
bad you're bad and it's not your fault i
was bad too i got stuff quick but i was
still bad you have to
like now i'm a much better comic than i
was [ __ ] 10 years ago obviously
because i've been working way more and
way harder but um
but yeah i think that uh
don't post your stuff you're gonna want
to you're gonna want to be that [ __ ]
crowdwork tick tock guy that gets
[ __ ] people to come you want it gonna
be a
comedy more than anything is in the arts
is a marathon it's not a [ __ ] sprint
and i've always [ __ ] asked you why
don't you stand up and the reason is
matt hates [ __ ] stand up yeah i'm not
in stand up um
i never really was i there's there are
people who do stand up that i'm like wow
they're [ __ ] so great there are a lot
of those people actually
and if i'm
if i go to a show i will laugh and enjoy
yeah he's not sitting there
no
that being said it's never a thing i
want to go to i want to put on the tv if
i'm going to sit down and put something
on i want it to be
a movie i don't want to [ __ ] watch
some person
unless i'm a huge fan of theirs like
i'll [ __ ]
i'll put on [ __ ] chris rock special
or some [ __ ] uh obviously i've been to
your shows a lot and enjoyed myself yeah
but also directed my last special so and
i yeah and i don't
i don't not enjoy it
when i'm there but it's just zero
percent of my you have to be a fan of
the person really it's not that's right
stand up isn't even also you um
you were like
when i first started doing stand up i
was like why don't you do it or
something and you were like what do you
got to do to just like hang out like
every night and i said yeah and he was
like you're like i don't want to do that
i don't want to do that at all yeah so
yeah i get that you're a [ __ ] you're
a you're a hermit a bit i am a little
bit of a hermit yeah and i'm it's too
bad too because you have excellent
shirts to show yeah i mean now that i
have this podcast though i don't need to
socialize it's true sit at home until i
do this every [ __ ] week but yeah
that's the reason he's doing three
minutes huh i wonder what he might be
doing the comedy story if he's in he
could really hack it in he could get
like six minutes worth because he talks
so [ __ ] yeah true yeah the guy could
do his half hour special in three
minutes
another thing about cell phones
um yeah have you seen the news today
uh
good luck dude it already happened but
good luck and keep going that's cool man
i love it
let's see your next one
hey guys so i recently broke up with
someone and found myself in a new
relationship two weeks later
i'm currently in that relationship i'm
very happy with my decision however i
can't help but feel a little bit guilty
for maybe moving on too fast
i just want to know your guys thoughts
on moving on from a relationship and
um if there's an appropriate time that
you should weigh before moving on
thanks guys
no
the answer is absolutely not there's no
appropriate amount of time you're
supposed to wait
yes
yeah do what you want yeah she's doing
what she wants dude she's living that
hedonistic lifestyle you know
she still looks like somebody from
toronto can't believe she's not but she
could be living in toronto yeah but i i
sensed though she thought she was from
there what i sensed was yeah she was
foreign and i was right so i went no no
no no you can't do that well you're
usually american and i want to see that
you can't see that you're wrong and then
scoot into rightness that's my whole
life yeah i know and you're scooting
into rightness my whole life i'm here to
tell you
you cannot scoot into rightness anymore
those days are over i'm here to put a
stop put a halt to your scoot and into
rightness
gore the god butcher and i'm thor
um
it's constipated
you're scooting into rightness
um
i'm here to put a stop into your scoring
the answer
is
no you met someone you fall in love with
them that's it doesn't matter if it
takes seven years or seven days after
you broke up from your previous
relationship it doesn't [ __ ]
matter it doesn't matter you do what you
do and don't listen to other people that
are like you know you should take a
little more time does it even mean if
she's not ready then she wouldn't be
dating a [ __ ] new person i guess so
yeah or she's just a sociopath and
doesn't [ __ ] love anybody and just
[ __ ] you know what i mean and then
even more than don't wait yeah true just
break harshness go just go yeah um
yeah you don't wait i mean it sucks for
the other guy i guess if he like loved
you and [ __ ] also like how long did you
go out with the person i don't know
there's no rule man like what's too long
anyway what's too short anyway you don't
know right you'd ask somebody and they'd
give you like somebody would say
three months somebody would say one
month somebody would say a year so it's
like it's not up to it's one of those
things that just whatever dude when i i
used to say this a lot of my podcasts
hedonistic lifestyle and of course i
don't mean just go and do whatever you
want if we're going to be real but also
you got to live what feels right to you
and if you're living what feels right to
you then you are what john lennon said
living
i don't know he doesn't even know
i only got only got to living he said
something like a [ __ ] a day of
uh jesus living
i don't remember what he said but john
whatever he was shot in the head so
maybe it was wrong he wasn't living
totally right because he died way early
but what i'm saying is
man and yoko ono really like seems like
she would be really annoying to hang out
with her nah i didn't watch the new
beatles doc and so everybody's mad at me
for that but apparently she really
wasn't in [ __ ] anything up she was
just hanging out
everybody would blame her for breaking
up the beatles and apparently in peter
jackson's new documentary
in the truth appears to be that she
actually was just sort of like hanging
out and was escaping peter jackson the
guy who did lord of the rings yeah
you didn't know he made that i know he
did lord of the rings no you didn't know
he made the new beatles thing i didn't
even know there was a new beatles thing
what the [ __ ] do you know why though
beetles are terrible that's not the
point it was like a cultural
moment like a like a like a big deal not
just in the music world but in like the
world
was the beatles you didn't know no i
know the beatles but i wasn't it's
called get back get back the beatles
what the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
called get back there it's getting back
the documentary when did it come out um
anthony was that last year it doesn't
yeah oh okay so recently yeah very
recently um i don't know man but what
i'm saying is yoko ono seemed annoying
just by kind of like looking at how she
handled herself
but let's get back to the [ __ ] thing
here okay let's get back to the thing
what was the thing the thing is a day
it's something like if you're living a
day of pleasure it's not wasted or
something because you're doing what you
want right and you're you're having a
good time
here's the thing you didn't need john
lennon because that's such a vague
general thing to say you could have just
said it's not a waste of time if you're
enjoying yourself
that's my quote that's i think that's
almost exactly what john lennon is okay
well me and him i guess are similar but
the point is you didn't need to take 30
minutes to try to come up with a quote
when you could have just said it in your
own words plainly it also could have
been one of those things where it was
like you know how everyone's like will
smith said this or chris hemsworth said
this and it's like shows a [ __ ]
picture of him in the hot tub and it's
like and then will smith is probably
looking at this [ __ ] like i didn't say
that chris hemsworth was like i didn't
[ __ ] say right yeah what kyle what's
going on i didn't [ __ ] say that wow
that is it chris hemsworth impressions
yeah that's so bad what is that
yeah charles
yeah what do you think about the way
chris hemsworth looks he's handsome as
[ __ ] i pissed next to him once you know
what my my shoulders are broader anyway
go ahead i i think
he is extremely handy he's handsome as
[ __ ] yeah but
i think say end instead of butt
otherwise it's so dead the end i think
not only is he amazing looking he looks
like
the dumbest guy
in the [ __ ] world
like think about it think about it think
about how [ __ ]
dumb he looks dude like i remember the
first still for thor when he came out i
i just started laughing because i was
like look how [ __ ] dumb this guy
looks dude why though i because he's
just like a big and bulky and blonde but
he's not really like yeah beautiful eyes
just like
probably okay what about uh [ __ ] the
one guy that uh kristen likes and
whatever it's not not a big deal i don't
know who jason moa right no he doesn't
look as dumb
but he's so big that guy yeah but he
doesn't look dumb to me
he looks like he's probably like read a
lot of poetry and has a lot of his brain
but chris hemsworth is like
doesn't know like what a book is that's
what he looks like you know wow yeah he
thinks like books are just things for
old people
like he he doesn't understand so ask me
about a book you think chris hemsworth
is like this
all right matt how's it going
yeah uh what'd you think of the great
gatsby i don't know yeah right it's good
the and he's just thinking about the
movie you know had it laying out of the
camera yeah we were up for the same part
right he would audition and almost get
the role and still not know
one day is that guy who's also in it
toby maguire he's good that actually
does sound like him that one the first
one you did sounded nothing like him hey
toby mcguire he's good yeah yeah um i'm
thor
it's like ask him about a book ask him
about a book um so
uh the sun also rises is a favorite of
mine i'm a thor
[Applause]
christian bale's in the new one
just can't
just when he freezes or doesn't know
what to say the sun also rises is what
it's called the sun also rises yeah
there's a movie
um
that
the guy who is in passenger 57 is in um
wesley snipes yeah he did a movie with
um
the guy who played james bond oh sean
conrad yeah
something about yes on rising sun that's
like that one
no but that is basically rising sun is
also based on a book right yeah
so do you know what a book is yep so
what they'll do is they'll do um tell me
what a book is
so i've read
books
a ton of books
i've read
the first book i read was batman returns
um
they make a movie right and then what
they'll do is
they'll do like a synopsis of it
and sell it in like
walgreens or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah batman returns is the first book i
read novelization is what that's called
after a movie is made they make a book
about it it's called a novelization
right the movie first which is crazy
because
it makes you think
how they made books
hundreds of years ago before film
existed right yeah this is by the way
exactly what he's like
for sure
i repeat next one once he's handsome his
[ __ ] my shoulders are broader but he's
more cut so you win some you lose he's
just more handsome in general than you
by like 10 10 times it's not like that
dude it's it's
honestly it's one of those things that's
like
you know yeah sure you can get the
cookie cutter [ __ ] or you can get the
dude where it's like yeah maybe some
people think he's handsome might be some
people don't but there's something no
everybody's extra special about him
don't say it for me thank you oh no i'm
saying for me yeah there's something
about him
for me people go like that about me
oh okay and i peed next to him and then
i go when he was like
or something i remember and then i
presented an award with kristen emilian
and he went like this
no he didn't but in his head he probably
didn't oh it was the people's choice
award is what it was okay and i
presented with christina milian okay and
who is
one of the most beautiful women in the
world i don't even know who that is
honestly she's a singer and that's why
yeah so she's great cool
so that's how the story ends i bet she
knows what books are
yeah um okay
let's do another one this is not the
right time you're just going to delete
brothers what's going on my name is
nolan uh
but [ __ ] nowhere mendocino california
i own and operate a licensed weed farm
down here checking on the ladies um
that brings me to my question these are
the ladies i spend the most time with
i'm originally from orange county shout
out laguna hills oh yeah laguna nigal
dana point um
okay growing up down there you know
there's a lot of attractive people and
uh now living where i'm at not so much
um
i like to think i have some kind of
standards when it comes to dating but
out here it's so limited i am
questioning my standards um
love to hear what you guys think if you
lived in the middle of nowhere where an
la4 is like a nine or a ten
you're out there smashing those fours or
you're sticking your standards and uh
just working hard you know that's all i
got to do out here so
love to hear what you guys think uh
thank you for putting out all your
content really appreciate it gets me
through my days all right later thanks
nolan
what i think about that
is
i think you're thinking about it the
wrong way actually you're you you
shouldn't apply your standard
to
the people that you encounter you need
to
experience the way the person you
encounter makes you
feel and i don't i don't mean like
necessarily just emotionally like
physically whether you're turned on by
someone or
wise
sure but like and then you
after that you apply sort of like the
thing you if you're doing it too
superficially from the outside you can
really get in your own way and just be
like a [ __ ] idiot who's just like not
up to my standards not up to my
standards not up to my standards but
like if you get in there first and like
don't have the idea of a standard in
your mind
and you're just experiencing the people
around you i think you have a probably a
better chance of finding someone
uh
attractive
than otherwise even when it comes to
physically like boner inducing [ __ ]
specifically that really yeah yeah yeah
so you're almost saying lead with your
heart
not really though no not really i'm
saying i think having a standard and
applying that before you
like thinking about that first and
foremost can get in your way of actually
finding someone attractive then why
doesn't he just do that with people and
not just chicks maybe he [ __ ] does it
with a dude and then falls in love with
the dude and sure that's a [ __ ] great
question yeah so you're saying maybe
he's gay possibly
or bi
definitely possible
nothing that he exhibited made me think
that right but yeah sure he could be
yeah
hmm um it's like when straight guys go
to all men all male jails they like
often have
long-term sexual relationships with the
men in jail they're not gay i would do
that
congratulations that's my not my point
if if what if you were in jail for life
would you [ __ ] up for life yeah
here's the thing i would [ __ ] guys if i
felt like [ __ ] guys there's not no
part of me that would if i felt like it
resist i would do it even if i didn't
feel like it i'd be like let's just
[ __ ] we gotta see what's up here oh
and i would do it
why
i mean like dude you're in there for
life and like
you just like you talk about like just
mixing it up [ __ ] why not okay yeah
hey bro what are you in here for oh [ __ ]
really capital murder yeah what are you
doing tonight you're right okay you
turned on by murderers no but like
you you like brian mcknight and you play
some and then you just you know what i
mean yeah that's the second time we've
talked about brian mcnair
so uh what's your [ __ ] advice i think
first of all this guy's let me just say
i get it this guy's in trouble
orange county
i don't know how often you've been to
orange county rare i'm rarely there but
dude the the women there
from like
i mean dude even like the
50 year old moms are like you would you
would gnaw your arm off to to [ __ ] go
out with they're so hot so but that's
where he was yeah that's where he's from
okay so this dude i mean i see it better
even better than i think better than
hollywood because like everyone comes to
hollywood and these models are all like
you know wafey and like fake looking but
bro you go to orange county they're a
little bit fake looking but like and
there's a lot of plastic surgery but
dude just the sun and the outdoor
relaxing living and then not trying to
prove anything and then not trying to
like
it's just they're so hot the the dude
like the guys will be looking dude the
dudes are good looking it's just like a
[ __ ] crazy good-looking place okay
and so now he's in minnesota i don't
know where the [ __ ] that is i know it's
got that aida minnesota farms but like
the people who work there are very ugly
but like the no no relation yeah no um
well i actually think that it is from
the place is from this is they're saying
yeah no correlation with people that are
serving you a [ __ ] sandwich in
mendocino farms right that has nothing
to do with the people the way that
people look in mendocino the place
probably
definitely i don't mean a bad mouth
well there's no correlation but it still
could be the same amount of
attractiveness level could be right yeah
so but that would be random not
correlated again i guess so but wow not
wanting to give anything
but um
i think
what makes you
he's it's rough because he's going from
one of the places where the [ __ ]
hottest people are to now a place where
he just wants to hang out with plants
right sure so like
you're young maybe work and let let this
[ __ ] come to you get on tinder or write
or whatever the [ __ ] is out there no
bumble bottom is a grinder matt thinks
you're gay so maybe get on if you're not
attracted to people around you then
don't force yourself to be attracted to
them yeah don't express yourself but
also lead with your you know like okay
well maybe and even matt saying like
meet dudes and maybe be open to like she
didn't say that matt's saying you know
maybe just [ __ ] some guys and like sure
if he wants to definitely right yeah but
i'm not suggesting it and you're making
it sound like i am mm-hmm uh yeah i
think it's uh a rough go dude because
like it'd be one thing if you moved from
[ __ ] peoria
but you did not no i'm telling you
that's the mecca of good-looking people
orange county
orange county
not
hollywood not dubai or whatever the [ __ ]
you know you see all these hookers post
post pictures in dubai and they're just
like i'm in dubai and you're like yeah
but who are you with though and she's
like just out here chilling in dubai and
it's like okay your pockets got fatter
you're hugging right yeah okay i mean i
don't know that to be perfectly honest
but i do okay if you're in dubai and
you're hot and you're alone
on social media
you're hooking okay okay okay so
this guy's in trouble and maybe
shack up with somebody not because of
looks if you're gonna live there forever
or still maybe set your tinder on on a
different place
and then really get to know them and be
be like by the way i'm in mendocino
mendocin whatever the [ __ ] you know by
the way but before you get all pissed
off
dude i know you're not gonna want to
come move here
check it out though we can be high all
the time uh-huh yeah look at this yeah
yep yeah offer what you got to get them
out there yeah that's right yeah okay
well
another one yeah let's do another one
look at this fella what's up bros this
is corey calling in from missouri big
fan of you well mostly chris cause i'm a
true baby and life rips but let's be
honest man if matt wasn't there to keep
you in check we'd all just be doing spin
moves and nothing would get done yeah i
just love the show though can't wait to
see more so here's what i need you guys
advice on today
my partner and i have been together
almost two years now very much in love
and she's got these two beautiful little
girls that just melt my heart they make
me feel like a better man and i would
love to be their dad one day the issue
is her her side of the family can be a
little bit toxic her mom in particular
is always trying to undermine her
parenting take control of things
disrespect our boundaries i don't think
she's a good influence on the kids
but my partner is still always sending
them over there to be babysat yeah and
it can be disruptive for me
and i don't think it's very healthy
so i'm just not sure what i should do do
i step in and try to keep them home more
or do i just kind of let it be and let
them figure it out and maybe it's not so
big a deal
let me know what you think thanks guys
peace out
i think you should go with that
depending on how toxic it is then they
are you know that's a word that's been
thrown around so much lately like you
don't even know if people mean it
anymore i'm gonna take this guy for what
he's saying as as face value though um
you know
that's kind of par for the course dude
is it just parents that do that just
like
grandparents and like also especially
like mother father-in-law
you know it's like this is just the
these are the issues you're gonna have
when you have a partner especially that
comes with kids and um i think that you
know
look i'm blessed to have [ __ ] great
grandparents for calvin and [ __ ] and
like um but you know even even with
great grandparents there's still things
that are just gonna like you're gonna
butt heads against it's a little tricky
though because you want to be their dad
and you're not their dad right um and
hopefully you're in love and she think
you know your partner thinks that you're
a great dad you would be a great dad and
maybe you can adopt them someday that
guy's definitely
would be a great deal i mean sure seems
like it right even though he likes you
more than he likes me he would be well
that's one of the reasons why he'd be a
great dad no um
and uh
you know
i just think that uh it's a uh
it's a tricky situation because you're
not technically her dad yet but you want
to be so in a way it's like
look
you got to act what you want you got to
act the way you want like if you're a
stand-up comedian you don't say i want
to be a stand-up comedian you get on
stage and you say i'm a stand-up
comedian well yeah what shows you do i
do open mics well that's not technically
what a stand-up community does was like
yeah but it is though every state of
queen is done set up open mics so i'm a
comedian [ __ ] off you got to live what
you want so if you want to be their dad
and the mom is cool with you possibly
being with their dad then start acting
like their dad and say to you know the
wife the wife your wife or your partner
um
you know
maybe
you got to open up dialogue and you got
to say like you know this is what your
mom did or this is what your dad did and
it's i feel like it's toxic to the kids
um how do you feel this way if she feels
the same way then offer
to watch the kids more because you know
if that's the direction that you're
going in then that's the direction
you're going in and that's direction
you're going to be in any way uh if you
will eventually be their dad which um
is hopefully going to happen for you um
what i what i was going to say actually
is
and i give great advice it ends up being
similar to what you said which is like i
think that
you are
in a position where you're like uh i
would say maybe on your way to being
their father figure being their father
basically
and
offer
because i don't know how bad these
people are like are they putting crazy
ideas in their head that are like that's
the interest for them in their future or
are they just like [ __ ] annoying like
sneaking them too much sugar on the side
like it's possible that's a big spectrum
he's saying toxic i know but still it
could be and it could be a lot of things
sugar is toxic what i would say
is
try to
be the person that fills up their time
instead like offer your own services
which is
kind of what you're saying to be the
person that watches them as much as you
can
and that also ends up covering ground
toward where you want to be which is
sort of like their father figure and you
will also be able to show her how
[ __ ] good you are at the job
oh yeah good it's like a you're like
you're a dad intern yeah yeah you're
interning and you're like maybe this is
what we should do for the fathership
right exactly yeah look at this well
taking [ __ ] pictures just in the
middle of this show what we want right
okay um so yeah uh i think that uh
that's good this guy's it's gonna be
fine this guy's got too good of a head
on his shoulder you know why and it's
like you could be like yeah but you
don't know that you don't know the
partner but like yeah but you wouldn't
have such a good head on your shoulder
if it wasn't or you wouldn't be with
somebody who's so [ __ ] insane if you
have that kind of a hat on yourself i
think the the woman in question is great
i think he's great and i think probably
the parents are a little [ __ ]
whack-a-doodle-dandies yeah yeah
i'm a whack-a-doodle sweetheart every
single note was the same you're tone
deaf let's do another one if you ever
said again your necklace your neck will
break hi my name is veronica i'm from
michigan
and i have a problem with my
mother-in-law well i'm not even married
but i've been with this guy for four and
a half years he's got three kids
um i've been living with them for over
three and he was born in costa rica well
his whole family lives over there like
his parents and his grandparents and the
mom comes over and stays with us for
like an entire month out of the year and
her
permanent address in the united states
is our house so we have to like go
through her mail constantly which is
annoying
and she's coming in two weeks
um the last time she was here i actually
saw on our nest camera in our living
room oh boy we had to put one up because
he has a teenage girl and you know boys
whatever yeah yeah anyway
i saw on the next camera that she like
because we have audio she was talking so
much [ __ ] about me i mean she was saying
how i come from a poor family i don't
know how to handle the kids i you know
and this and that
sounds out to no one and i need advice
on how to handle it this time around i
no longer have access to the nest
because i never wanted to hear somebody
say stuff like that about me again in my
own house
and uh
we don't even talk
like hardly at all so should i ignore
should i confront her she has no idea i
heard everything
thank you guys peace out you should
absolutely confront her absolutely
[ __ ] confront her and be like hey you
know i heard you talking [ __ ] about me
is there a problem yeah boom bing bang
boom
i'm a wacky doodle no sweet huh no no
you don't so you say uh
i mean yeah dude wow
dude caller [ __ ] out
got no do you know what
oh [ __ ] that's crazy you got no time for
this but you have to you have to tell
the guy first
you don't think she's told no no i'm
saying that you're going to talk to them
oh or or maybe have him deal with it if
it's his mom
hmm you know what i'm saying
i don't know i'm just trying to think of
like maybe
where like my like either kristen or my
girlfriends in the past have been like
hey this is happening can you talk to
your mom or dad about this what about
the other way around has it ever been
you have a problem
right with yeah the parent of your
partner
and you want your partner to handle it
instead of you i don't ever i'm just
like who cares yeah i would do it i
guess that's okay yeah well then i guess
i would do it yeah so well i would
definitely do it to the dad but not to
maybe not to the mom right
i mean i would do it to anybody i'm kind
of confrontational though so am i yeah
but um like that you are
yeah oh okay
yeah i mean i think she should do it but
if he doesn't want her to specifically
maybe he has a point maybe it would be
better if he did it better for both of
them but but i i don't know and i don't
pretend to know i'm just saying
that woman needs to be confronted what
is she doing talking [ __ ] about you
inside your house
that you let her stay yeah also who she
month out of the goddamn um
by the way i want to give props to this
[ __ ] lady for
saying you don't have access to this
nest cam anymore because you don't want
to hear that is such a grown-up way to
handle that i don't actually think i
understand can you tell me she's saying
she heard that and then she was like all
right i'm not checking this nest thing
anymore i'll have my husband deal with
it we have it all you know what i mean
like which is awesome that's like that's
like the number one way to deal with it
because why
[ __ ] have that [ __ ] enter your brain
if you don't need need it to be but
that's [ __ ] up dude she's getting yo
oh oh you want to get your mail at my
house yeah yeah oh walk in like that and
say that first that's what it should be
like oh you want to get oh with all the
mail just
letting it [ __ ] fall out of your
hands and be like but what's up with the
[ __ ] talk though
but what's up with this [ __ ] oh you
think because you get mail here that you
can talk [ __ ] about the other people
that live here well let me tell you how
it's gonna be and listen to hit him up
first listen to hit him up okay
when he's just like when i you know
i [ __ ] your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ]
and he's like by the end we got [ __ ] my
this is how we're going to do this [ __ ]
mob deep [ __ ] bat brother [ __ ] [ __ ] you
won't be done with them [ __ ] you two and
then approach her and be like oh you
want to get mail here [ __ ] i think that
might i mean i just said i was
confrontational but i think that might
be a bit much like this because then i
think you might immediate i think you
might immediately enter being in the
wrong yeah but also you'd be like this
how we do it in [ __ ] america dude and
then play lean back
[Laughter]
and then be like and then with the nest
cam just showing her
and then you have to lower the music
because hold on let me let me make this
louder this is what you did so two songs
this is such a time commitment well you
play the tupac thing and then you go in
and then you do it with the [ __ ] lean
back [ __ ] while you're doing it and then
you turn down the volume of lean back
and then you turn up the nest cam and be
like i heard you're doing this what
about just going up there and saying hey
i heard you i don't know if you knew
this but you were actually
on camera documented on video talking
[ __ ] about me in my house would you mind
telling me what that's about that would
be ball if i'm the lady do you know what
i do no i i don't speak english i'm from
but but she knows she knows that you can
speak speak to me as a later i am from
costa rica i don't know [ __ ] idiot go
ahead say well i heard you talking [ __ ]
in english about me i was guessing words
[Music]
yeah well yeah
okay i don't know what i say english why
that would be maddening you know oh that
would be the best dude
then you'd have a right to kick her out
of your house yeah maybe yeah
the guy should be really mad though
yeah you know what i mean
just he should be [ __ ] not his wife
like come on
come on mom it'd be so hard to [ __ ]
do that with your parents you know do
what to be like you were talking [ __ ]
about my wife i think it would be so
easy to be like hey mom
stop talking [ __ ] about it but you know
mom our house but you know moms the next
generation like your mom's dad but like
the next generation's gonna be like i
didn't do that [ __ ] or you know what she
needs to this you know moms you know
yeah but
especially if she's already saying like
you know you don't deal with the kids
right or whatever the [ __ ] you're not
you're a bad mom she thinks she's a bad
mom she's like well you know i i've been
doing this i'm [ __ ] yeah you know
i've been i've raised kids i raised you
and she needs to this and that you know
how it goes still though
even
even more so though
even more so whatever
more so like oh yeah just get it out
yeah [ __ ] open call her out to her
face look her in the [ __ ] eye look
her right in the [ __ ] eye
have that nest cam ready though she said
she doesn't have access to anyone i know
but have the husband give her that ready
to be like you know slide it on over i
say i say set up more cameras cut try to
catch her doing it again
and get several different angles of it
and then get take the footage and then
cut it together like super dramatic yeah
yeah like a good movie scene
and then say we all want to sit down and
watch a family movie oh wow with her
there and put it on that's great and
everyone's looking at the screen you
just stare at her yeah and hire richard
hired [ __ ] david attenborough to do
the [ __ ] that would be good yeah
yeah and watch the mother-in-law yeah
talk right mad [ __ ] yeah yeah we thought
it was all good but did you know that
mother-in-law's especially from a
generation above you talk [ __ ] about you
yeah
yeah
she bad at parenting
it could be expensive to get him to do
it probably really expensive yeah
um
yeah okay want to do one more or what do
we have one more all right
what's up guys so i've been a huge fan
of yours for the longest time
specifically because your family dynamic
is so similar to mine wow that all of
your stories make me go
they get it ah nice like everything from
the a little bit more toast button to
like the number of pieces of meat in the
spaghetti yeah the amount of sauce on
the calamari is just i can totally
imagine having these conversations with
my dad
except we have our own situations my dad
once put alfredo sauce on his salad
ate the whole thing
and never realized it wasn't ranch
dressing whoa
wow so i feel like advice from you is
going to be all the more relevant huh i
moved to china in 2018
and i've been here since then now at the
very beginning it was great like my
parents would come and visit once a year
and i would go home once a year and so
it was
ideal get to see my family and i get to
have my awesome job that i have here i
get to be with my awesome girlfriend i
live in an awesome apartment just like
my whole life quality situation was
amazing
the then covet happened
and they completely shut down travel
here
so if i leave there's no guarantee i can
come back right and if i do
finally manage to come back i need to do
a mandatory three weeks of quarantine
before i can do anything
so like there's no like hey job can i
have off for a month in three months i'm
sorry a month in three weeks yeah right
so
i haven't seen my family in two and a
half years damn
and i'm kind of at the point where it's
like how much longer can i do this yeah
because
i planned on living here this wasn't
like a temporary yeah i really like
being here i speak the language like
i've
i've settled down here but at the same
time like
how long can i go with just never seeing
my family
and it's just getting suckier all the
time my family met up for christmas and
they all had this awesome time together
and
not me
wow
that sucks this place here is called
latina huh
next it's relevant
so what do you think i should do
latina
um
a two and a half year i'm trying to
i mean dude if you didn't see your uh me
for two and a half years
it's a really long time ah but it's
already been two and a half years how
much longer could it possibly be from
now well yeah that but that's what he
probably said a year in he did but now
it's even more true
or it's just going to keep going
yes i mean i don't know what it's like
what else can he do
he's going to move back home but he's in
a situation where he's with the [ __ ]
love of his life and he has his dream
job
what is it now well how come his parents
can't come out there because it's
they're just old and they they don't
want to quarantine too
why don't they just move you know old
people you know what dude it's kind of
if
i don't know how old they are he looks
kind of youngish but like
maybe
you could you couldn't ask mom and dad
to move to [ __ ] china i could not
yeah like i could not you're saying yeah
you know they would say no well yeah
because they're they work but if dad i
don't know the different situation
though if if i had a grandkid and mom
and dad were 75 and they were done
working
i mean you know mom and dad would come
out for
six months yeah at a time yeah you know
what i mean so but i don't know what
their situation is
that's true maybe they could yeah you
know i mean they're older and if they're
retired then it's i think i think you
should delegate
also if the [ __ ] dad ate fettuccine
sauce on his salad thought it was
ranching no what the [ __ ] is going on he
doesn't even know where he is put him in
china he doesn't even know you'd be like
this is [ __ ] still nashville or
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah you know i
would be like oh it looks different
everyone has tans but like
you know yeah and they cough in your
faces but we don't know about the mom
though yeah she might notice
i mean if she's with a uh i guess i
don't know man i mean i think it's i
think i think it's fair to say it's
definitely a little bit more on
the older generation the mom and dad
your mom and dad to figure something out
a little bit more but but then again
it's not just his mom and dad it's his
whole family right he said yes it's his
sister brother so maybe
so they're not going to move just for
him so yeah it is kind of more on him i
think just wait i think china's not
going to have a zero covert policy for
another two years it might be another
one year but dude you've been two and a
half into it just wait one more year
yeah and then go home for a whole month
wait a little bit yeah yeah i think the
move is to just wait a little bit more
now you're so if you're in it you're so
deep into it just bear down and keep
going yeah and also like
when you show up
bring some alfredo sauce yeah but
that'll be so sweet to be man i would
cry so much that's uh
oh that's rough bro that sucks man yeah
what bad timing you had when you moved
to china bad bad job yeah it's his fault
bad job at
having timing
when it comes to moving
yeah
but i like that guy's energy he was
really good i loved that yeah yeah seems
like you're doing well anyway even
though you haven't seen your family but
also like dude you know this is part of
like growing up and becoming like now
you're the guy who has the relationship
with the woman and like you're gonna
maybe have kids and [ __ ] these are like
the decisions god being an adult [ __ ]
sucks dude yeah my son was running
around you know what he was doing he had
a bunch of dice like eight no like ten
dice in in a [ __ ] i had no i i had
nose uh i had a what do you call it a
bacteria in my nose i went to the nose
doctor gave me pills and it's all
cleared up and the pill bottle is empty
and calvin's like ah he wanted the
[ __ ] pill bottle and he took a bunch
of dice and just put it in the pill
bottle he's just carrying around all day
that's what we did all day yesterday i
left today that was doing all day today
and he just look at my beaut beautiful
dice that's what he says for beautiful
look at my beautiful dies in that little
pills bottle and all he does is just
dump it out pick it out and put it back
in man that's the [ __ ] dude that's the
[ __ ] and now we got to deal with
[ __ ] like this my son doesn't know
about cove he's just picking up
beautiful dice
yeah
that sounds so [ __ ] boring i know but
he loves it yeah yeah sure yeah
yeah just do what you love man you know
there's a thing that john lennon said
just like if you're living a day of
pleasure then it's not wasted
and uh listen to john lennon and shack
up with your girlfriend and go to
chlitla and whatever i think waited out
dude i think waited out also how much
was that guy in a [ __ ] gus van sam
movie in the late 90s that guy was
inside he was like the third lead in the
best fantasy movie also it looked like
in that video it was a hundred and ten
degrees away it looked like he looked so
hot it looked like nothing he was
sweating
right yeah amazing dude we're good
detectives yeah all right um so that's
the show for today thank you very much
go to crystalia.com
for tour tickets i'm going to be in
atlanta washington peoria i'm going to
be in stockton oakland i'm going to be
in jacksonville i'm going to be in grand
prairie texas i'm going to be in that's
right grand prairie texas i haven't even
announced that one yet whoops um and uh
i'm gonna be in boston massachusetts
jacksonville uh and denver so and other
places so go to chrisley.com i
remembered all of it if you have
questions for us it's not just about you
i don't know if you knew that if you
have questions for us yeah
send the video uh link is in the
description below or go to
watchlifeline.com
and also there's this out now the
christmas christmalia.com there's this
out now and also the life rips the new
life rips hoodie and then also we're
working on lifeline merch right now yeah
so guys get it uh watchlifeline.com and
uh appreciate you and also activate that
algorithm and leave advices for those
people that uh that they check the
comments too so leave advice and we'll
reply to some of them on the youtube
comments thanks a lot guys you rock
yeah
hello
[Music]
hello hello